okay
i'm trying to fix my hair
i did brush it this morning so
you did all right i did yeah i used your
brush remember oh yeah you did you did
okay guys um
so question ellie why are you trending
on twitter today
i'm training on twitter and tick tock
because we did a video on tick tock that
got 1.4 million views because apparently
society is so broken that you can go
viral for being a happy housewife a
happy housewife okay yeah
so hold up hold up
sorry i wanna put my sweater on
okay
so
why do you think this is like crazy
information
well i think
that women want a break
right and i think that there are
actually women out there too that know
that they're not single and childless on
purpose and it's by default that they
didn't have the tools and the
information that they had because if you
think about it it's like half of the
comments are women who are upset with me
because i'm like a housewife and i'm
letting my man like dominate me which it
doesn't make any sense like i don't even
have an allowance
like that's not even what's going on and
then on the flip side
it's women coming forward and saying oh
my god i would love that or or this my
favorite one is the third one where
women are coming forward and saying yeah
i did it i worked hard a lot i decided
to go part time or i decided to quit my
job and we've all been happier ever
since
and okay so
why
what is the main like angry comments
that you get
the main inks is just that people say
that i'm promoting something that could
be toxic it could be women in a
vulnerable position but that really
neglects the family laws where you can
just upbeat half his stuff like you can
get pregnant baby courts and child
support like that's how bad the laws are
women are put in a vulnerable position
in marriage i think they're just spoiled
it'll go back i i got i got verizon they
don't they don't do that you got to
write in yeah you're rich now yeah
okay but
so
you go trending on twitter
you got these [ __ ] mad because
like the women that are mad at you
are like they actually want to be you
i don't i don't know that they
want to be me because i think a lot of
women objectify men
because what i have it's not just that
you know he gives me a break when it
comes to my energy expenditure in the
workforce or anything like that it's
like he also loves me cherishes me
protects me like i don't worry about my
safety and my husband's presence so i
don't think women take it that deep i
think most women just want to have that
opportunity to have a break when it
comes to being able to exit capitalism
when they need to but i think we want to
write like uh you know me i work pretty
hard like i like working but the thing
is like when i have kids like i i want
to be home with them and you want to be
with a guy that you can like depend on
to like go off like to take off work for
a couple years when they're young yeah
and so like the whole financial
responsibility doesn't just fall on your
shoulder
and it's like women were so
unwilling to relinquish people like i
think it's a control thing i think it's
a control thing too because i know a lot
of
well i'm not going to say a lot i know a
handful of women that they could afford
to stay home and they would really
thoroughly enjoy like cooking and
cleaning and having that free time to do
something like hiking but they still
have it like programmed in their head
that they have to work or like they have
pressure from their parents to be a
worker and to me that's crazy because
the funniest part about you know staying
home we're like what are you gonna do
with all your free time i'm like
favorite girl like whatever you want to
do
if you want to open a six figure
business out of your own kitchen like
you can and that's the thing like i i
understand like the freedom that you
have a little bit just because like like
i know i always have my parents to fall
back on and so i when i moved home for a
year and lived with my parents like i
was able to do whatever i wanted with
that creativity and it's so freeing to
just be able to do what you're like
creative and like passionate about i
wouldn't have a youtube channel if it
wasn't for my husband i wouldn't have
been able to take that risk now for men
you know they got to like pull out
business loans for that i just was like
nah like hypergamy
you were looking at the comments yeah i
was just seeing any good ones um pearly
thing said eight months
ago that the court system is not fair to
men do you agree with that i agree and
what i think is weird about modern women
is that they have sons they have uncles
and they have fathers
you know but they're just like so quick
to like run up on their baby daddy
sometimes
and like to be like to be absolutely
toxic to stress that man's life out i'm
like you do realize that could happen to
your son and then and then they'll talk
about they'll talk about how
how toxic they're like the men they pick
are yeah and like i've been in toxic
relationships and it was my own damn
fault yeah
i picked him i picked him so you're
gonna you're gonna get mad
because you pick trash man maybe stop
picking trash men that's what i was
saying like they wouldn't get triggered
unless it was close to the truth because
i remember when i wasn't happy and i
would get i was miserable i would get
triggered like you know any time you get
triggered about my weight you want to
know when it is is when i don't go to
the gym
it's like i don't go to the gym yes you
can't call me back when i'm slim thick
because i know i look good
[Laughter]
[Music]
but that's the only time i'd be feeling
insecure and it's my own damn fault oh
talk about okay let's talk about
submission submission oh god everybody
likes that one so they they hate the the
females the people they think it's the
patriarchy they're just the men they're
so evil because they want you to submit
yeah
tell me tell me about that
well
submission is it's kind of i'm probably
going to end up talking about this for
10 solid minutes so
the way that submission works and you
have to just throw away the pink
definition of it because that is it's
not the same thing trust me like
submission in marriage was a thing
before there was like you know absurd
whips chains and floggers like that's
not what we're talking about it's kind
of weird that people take it in that
immediate direction
but
submission is not being a quarrelsome
woman and letting a man lead the only
man that's not going to be okay with a
submissive woman is going to be a man
that needs his woman to lead him and
that's not a man that most women find
attractive but the thing about it is is
uh
not every woman needs to do
psychological healing and submission
work so i live in the midwest the
standard out there is a two-parent
christian household i will say in my
county 76 white but it's some of the
most well-rounded women out there
they're kind and they understand when
there's a trusted proven and justified
authority they'll submit to that
authority and i mean like mentorship in
college or like talking to their manager
or respecting their parents or
respecting the elderly and things like
that so it's like women that grow up in
a lower socioeconomic status with poor
modeling they need submission work
because uh the reason why i like kevin
samuels and how he would call out black
women is because
i'm puerto rican and so we have like
similar problems where we're out here
absolutely prepared to curse out and
fight men and then complaining that
we're single meanwhile our kids suffer
because of it and like me as a minority
woman i'm like no way like i can figure
this out so i had to learn how to not be
argumentative like i was when i was
first with my my husband we were dating
like it took a long time for me to stop
being rude because that was my baseline
and i had already done some work on it
okay so this is like really sad that i i
did work to be less rude just to be like
eh you need to do more but that i don't
talk any i did not talk any differently
than the women in my family that came
before me i thought it was normal and i
didn't know that when you disrespect men
they don't feel love but once i figured
that out i was like well that's not nice
yeah like okay well i wanted to feel
like i love him
yeah
and why why do you think it's so hard
for us as women to like submit to a man
oh because most most men are not worth
submitting to legitimately most men are
true yeah
yeah so like my husband is a a trained
fighter uh he's trained with weapons
he's got the financial piece down he's
got his fitness down like of course i'm
naturally gonna fall in line because the
man can do anything and everything to
protect me like i don't even worry about
my life
i have no fear
so
that's what women don't have is access
to the masculine men that are willing to
go that far to protect them and would do
anything for them and it's like like
people act like i'm chained in the
kitchen or something but if i'm sick
like he takes care of me where if i'm
feeling like you know blue he'll bring
chocolate so like of course i'ma follow
his leaves and the thing is like the
women will say things like oh you can't
trust a guy to like stay at home because
like you you miss out on like work
opportunity but i'm like so but maybe he
can't trust you to spend money on you
well you're home like i'm like he could
go the same way
so it's like relationships are always
going to be a risk
so
so like why why are we freaking out when
we have to take a risk they have to do
it too they can lose their [ __ ] i
actually so i wrote about this last
night
uh let me see if i can pull it up but
the the thing about young men and young
women what they want out of the dating
market or like whatever they end up
putting out that's vitriol it's because
they're like they're looking at the fear
what if this fails what if this happens
if you decide to pursue romance you're
going to encounter fear like it's not
it's not safe like my husband could wake
up tomorrow and be like well that was
fun we get out of my house yeah you're
like i don't i don't worry about that
because i don't i don't want to live in
fear and that can really like overtake
your mind as a woman so i ended up
writing this i said i get asked this
question a lot about marriage what if
she leaves him what if he leaves her if
you want risk-free romance stay in
situation shifts because no one comes
out of human romance entirely unscathed
and this is the harsh reality that's why
people push back people can't stomach
that people don't leave people they're
afraid of losing and this is for both
men and women alike so if you've ever
been left by someone to them you were
worth leaving
yeah
yeah that's that's really good
if you want each other in a marriage
like then you're gonna stay if you're
afraid to be without them you're gonna
stay and that doesn't have to be like a
horrible awful fear you know it's not
it's not about like oh my god if i leave
it my life is over
it's like oh if i if i leave i'm like my
life's going to be messed up and i'm not
going to be happy so of course you want
to stay oh other questions so
i i said on my channel people were like
mad at me because i said i think you
should stay in shape for your husband
and i think no i swear that like i think
you should stay in check for your
husband and i think it's disrespectful
to get overweight like if you're in a
marriage and i'm not saying like you're
obviously your body's gonna change with
kids but like if you just completely let
yourself go and get obese i'm like that
is disrespectful to a guy because you're
you're like you represent him yeah and
like people were so mad at me for saying
that because i'm like fellas you don't
have to take the [ __ ] leave the whales
yeah leave them and i'm not talking
about girls that are trying i'm talking
about girls that get fat oh yeah and
aren't doing anything about it and have
no intention to ever do anything about
it like yeah girl what do you expect
yeah it's pretty ridiculous but those
women just don't care how their husbands
view them like their husband's probably
an accessory because if they genuinely
were confronted by hey you know you're
putting on some weight they're like oh
my gosh like i'm really sorry i'm gonna
go work on that and i have to say that
most of the women that i know that are
in happy marriages they do have
traditional masculinity and femininity
in a way
you know like in modern times it's just
that like the man leads but they care
how they look for their husbands they
will work out like kansas is full of
housewives like that like legitimately
so i like basically if you decide to get
fat and not do anything about it for
your husband i know you're not feeling
him that much unless you know he's like
fat with you too because i've seen some
couples like drop out together yeah if
you all frump out evenly like i get it
but if your man is finer than you i'm
like ma'am but you know you know what
happens um
so when you get pregnant it's the
cravings you only need to have 200 extra
calories a day to sustain a pregnancy
but there's different things that you
end up craving so i know women that have
gained 40 or 60 pounds usually yeah like
the first pregnancy though but what i
will say is like the women that care
about their husbands they will take the
two years
[Music]
yeah
well and the thing is i've noticed men
some of these kindest things that have
ever been done for me or like by men
yeah and i think when you're actually
like a good kind woman and like honestly
they'll do this for rachel sometimes too
like but like guys dude we'll go above
and beyond because i just think it's in
their nature to like protect and help
and so i don't understand like why these
girls hate men for no reason when and
like the men you hate you pegs
yeah no i i gotta say like
i don't think i was ever programmed to
hate men but i was definitely programmed
not to trust men but i was so smart when
i was a kid i would look at the women
complaining about men and telling me you
know you just could never trust them
like get a job looking like i'm pretty
sure you just picked wrong and i would
be like eight years old i'm like ma'am
no because brad next door him and his
wife are happy like they're happy so
like what did you do
what did you do
and the crazy thing okay these girls
that want these like super rich guys
yeah i'm like do you think that man just
expects you to do nothing oh my god i'm
sorry i'm sorry my dad he's in the one
percent like do you do you think that
man
just wants you to sit down and look
pretty no he does he's gonna expect you
to do [ __ ] he's gonna expect you to put
your time and effort into raising maybe
homeschooling kids right or like my mom
had to help my dad like run his business
i don't even want to say had to help she
got to help him yeah
oh yeah and it's like these girls just
think that like they can just do nothing
it's so funny okay because yeah most
women honestly are not quality enough to
be housewives i'm just gonna be honest i
am familiar with uh military spouses
but um
so i think i think what i wanted to say
is that even the pretty girls that just
stay home and look pretty you know like
that's like that's the job you have to
stay as hot as possible they'd be in the
gym two or three hours yeah they they'd
be hungry yeah they they're not eating
charlie
surely
we've both been overweight dude i was
almost obese i was over 200 pounds yeah
that's the thing you can lose it it made
me sick my ankles hurt my joints hurt
six months you could be a whole new
person yeah you could
you just don't want to be
well it's like if you know if being
obese was healthy i probably wouldn't
bring it up but like people are quick to
to knock somebody for smoking cigarettes
but they're not quick to knock somebody
for not being able to put down the fork
and like that was hard for me losing 45
pounds was genuinely hard but you know
what i ended up finding out was that
like i enjoy working out and eating well
it made my life better if women would
just have the fortitude to go to the gym
for at least 30 days
they would they probably would keep
going but most people don't even work up
to that
right and it's like women want us to be
quiet about the fact that they're
predisposing themselves to heart disease
strokes diabetes like everything even
cancer we're like pcos and they want us
to put this on the magazines yeah
see your rolls becky like if it's like
i'm opening a magazine i'm i'm straight
i'm straight as an arrow but i swear to
god i'm opening up a magazine to see a
hot model
i want to see what i'm not i want to
feel a little bit bad about myself
yes i want to be humbled that's why i
opened the magazine
but now you're now we're going we got we
got these rolls yeah you got these rolls
yeah it's just it's not a good message
for women so you know the number one
killer of women in the united states is
heart disease and it's like
that's from obesity that's that is from
obesity that's slim dick you're just
thick yeah yeah but it's okay
people don't want to cope with the fact
that like they actually are in pain i've
had obese people say
uh that they're healthy because their
blood work is healthy i'm like i know
you can't even move your legs the way
that they were evolved to i'm like run a
mile yeah like a mile don't get stress
fractures but anyway
let's see any good comments in here
yeah oh how do you feel about being i
saw one how do you feel about being a
pikmi what do you think what do you
think about
what do you think about being a picnic
um i mean i think i got picked right and
i think people get on the ranks
yeah well i think the thing about it is
i know i'm not insulted by being called
a pick me
but what a pick me really is is that a
woman that is like so desperate for any
man to choose her and i wasn't desperate
for any man i was only desperate for my
husband i was like please sir sir will
you marry me well you marry me it wasn't
like just a free world advertisement out
there and that's that's what guys don't
understand like
like the type of desire you want a girl
to like have for you like yeah like i i
think rob rollo says it's so true like
that she doesn't want to get married she
wants to marry you yeah like like you're
the guy whose baby she wants to have
and
like i don't
me why is that a understand thing like i
want to get picked by somebody because
people are saying this [ __ ] about me i'm
like i don't say this [ __ ] because i
don't believe it yeah that's just how
that's going to be that's a decision i
made 3 000 videos if i was incongruent
to my beliefs you would see it i made 3
000 videos all y'all that want to be on
youtube make 3 000 videos and then come
[ __ ] talk to me
hey come talk to me
pull up
pull up to the street yard no because he
will be like how do i make i'm like
three make three thousand bit like
but i'm like you haven't even made five
you haven't even made five you don't
have to make three thousand trust me i
did way too much work but like
try five
yeah yeah
no no i hear you like i think women are
not very good entrepreneurs but also the
whole pikmi thing it's just like calling
somebody like a loser it's like the most
childish thing a woman can do like men
don't go around doing that stuff
like what are the words that men call
other men it's not something like like a
pick him
what do you mean
like
they use words like broke they use words
like beta and i feel like that's i mean
obviously there's crosswords too
but like women just have so many stupid
childish words to call each other i'm
like ma'am
you graduate high school are we done yet
yeah
they can't figure out why they're single
yeah
like you're single because you're 14
psychologically that's why oh my god and
then we have the women that are dating
like they're 22.
they're 22. ma'am you're 45.
man
yeah oh my god then
another thing that happened to me was
are you thinking about it i'm thinking
about my words oh she's choosing her
words carefully while that's going on we
can pick out a little comment okay okay
let's see
also guys if you said super chats we'll
answer the comments any comments oh well
look the troll is here he says
my my past husband was my employee no he
wasn't okay am i occurring
let me take this one dude let me take
this one just like you guys can leave
the whales okay i give you guys
permission if your wife okay i i give
you this is a female i'm giving you
permission if your wife
gains a bunch of weight okay you have
talked to her about it because some of
y'all won't have that conversation
because you're scared of your wives okay
that is not my problem that like that is
not my problem so if you're afraid of
your wife if you can't have that
conversation
not my problem like that that's a you
problem but you've had this conversation
she's not trying not doing anything
she's not making taking any steps to get
there you can tell she's never gonna get
there right i
am giving you permission to leave the
whales you can leave them but at that
same token okay
we can leave the bombs dude we can leave
the bombs if a dude will not work
if he will not work if he refuses to
work i'm sorry i'm gone yeah i'm gone i
know i know men want to say what's that
true love for your personality no you
like me because i'm hot right i'm a fine
ass [ __ ]
and here's the thing
if i gain 100 pounds i wouldn't expect
you to stay
i wouldn't expect you to say so if
you're gonna do nothing
all day i'm i'm cooked gone and marriage
is about duty and responsibility yeah
and if you're not doing your duty or
your responsibility i'm sorry goodbye
yeah
no i can talk about it i can talk about
it so like i try to be as like silent as
i can be about my ex-husband because i
think my platform's gonna get bigger and
i don't really want people bothering him
because he didn't do anything wrong he
wasn't a bad husband he just wasn't the
right husband
for me he's not a bad guy he's a good
man he just has horrible work ethic
horrible work ethic is like the worst
and i i got with him because like all
right like i'm gonna hold this man down
through his 20s and my 30s it's going to
be a come up like we're going to be
successful together but then like things
started happening and he got lazier
and lazier and lazier serving money from
his mother from his mother instead of
getting a job he's borrowing money from
her and it's like there's so many other
things like again i don't want to put
all the info out there but if you had to
ask somebody to work for a year and a
half you would leave them too
you would leave them
like like we
you guys you have all these requirements
for women and i am so much for like men
should have standards i i i am with you
guys 100 of the way but like i'm sorry
if you're a good woman in today's day
and age if you're willing to submit if
you're willing to stay in shape if
you're willing to do the things that are
like a wife is supposed to do
i'm sorry
it's okay to not want to stay with a
bomb
well here's the thing it's like it's
hard to stay in love with somebody if
you go into the food pantry especially
if the dude don't got cancer like it's
like different if he's disabled but you
got two legs you guys away
and some of you guys let's talk about
this and i was working some of you guys
some of you guys want these quality
women like you'll complain about women
all day but what women do you qualify
for you know if you're not working if
you're not working going to the gym like
doing doing the things you're supposed
to do yeah like how is a girl supposed
to trust you to lead in in a family like
how is she supposed to depend on you if
if she can't if you can't even depend on
yourself if you can't even commit to
yourself to staying loyal to your job
staying loyal to going to the gym to
staying loyal to the doing the things
that you're supposed to do as a guy like
how are we supposed to trust you yeah
and that once you lose a woman's trust
you can almost never get it back and
like sometimes it takes like six months
or a year to get to get it back do you
know how stressful it is when you feel
like you're with a guy that just can't
figure [ __ ] out dude okay physically
tell okay you tell them your physical
manifestation i'll tell them my physical
manifestation what physical like how how
bad relationships make you sick oh yeah
it makes you sick like i got acne once
because like you feel like you're
what we choose to like put up with right
it's own fault right but but like
literally it is so strong
so stressful on a woman
the two um
to be like to be carrying the
relationship and feeling like you have
to figure literally everything out yeah
like like that's not that's not what
we're programmed to do yeah and
now it says audio
we're we're gonna we're gonna see if we
can get the audio back guys we'll find
out all right guys guys guys tell me
first if you can hear me yeah put a one
in the chat yeah one in the chat it was
someone called me so i'm gonna cut out
for a second yeah um
we'll see i'll check the chat oh they
can hear you they go okay
if someone just called me someone from
ohio
um
but but
one it's out of sync though what does
that mean chinese dub version
i don't know if that means one
oh okay okay they're saying it's like
it's it's just coming in and out yeah
okay i think it's better now yeah i
think we're good um okay but but that's
the thing like
like if you guys want dependable wives
if you want like the women that you guys
talk about like they exist like they'll
they'll stay on fresh and fit oh like
these these virgins they don't exist
like i'm like no you just don't qualify
for them oh yeah i agree i i know
i know probably
like eight virgins over the age of 22.
yeah well i mean i know a handful just
being in the midwest and a lot of these
guys
they could never get them and i don't i
don't mean that because some of these
guys are attractive but it's like their
decision making skills suck and if i'm
gonna trust you with all of my sexual
agency like you better have it together
sir like i need a good program and it
doesn't have to be you know
necessarily something that's complete if
you can prove action steps then like
yeah i think a woman can make it work in
the 20s but the thing is that modern men
don't want to admit that like most 20
year old dudes can't even do that they
can't make a woman a five year plan and
check boxes along the way and here's the
thing i think most girls would rather
have potential than a guy that's there
in my opinion yeah like i think like a
lot of girls like want to be the one
that's like like building the guy up but
you have to show her the qualities that
you're a guy that can be like built up
yeah still out of sync i think it's
going to be always in and out of sync
you don't think oh okay maybe not yeah
um i personally don't think
new husband on her new okay yeah
okay thank you for the super chat guys
uh five dollar super chat
from nick the actor sea world's new
slogan it should be leave the wheels i
should trademark this you
but then you'll get cancelled even more
are they talking about this in an uber
yeah our uber driver is actually really
cool we're nice
honestly that's probably the most
entertaining conversation this man ever
had
oh man it's nuts so you know what um
i'll say this is that i i got it
so i just didn't have a very good
marriage and like i wasn't perfect in it
either that's why i'm saying like he's
not a bad guy
i'm not a bad person either but i
definitely like sucked as a wife but
that the reason why i come out and i say
this stuff is because my life has been
an entire 180 and it's not just
hypergamy it's like compatibility
to like not be stressed out and
resentful every time you see somebody
yeah and it made me it gave me back
spasms it gave me and what i think it
gave me like
food allergies because i had two really
big food allergies i got sick uh because
of my genetics a couple of years ago in
2018. and i think some of that could
have been the stress from like how awful
my marriage was because i had to be the
husband
yeah but but with my current husband
i i lost the the two main food allergies
which was like rice and sesame and i'm
gluten free so like i couldn't eat
anything well and here's the thing like
like you're a hard worker like that's
why i like that's what we're friends
because like she she's a hard worker
like women will work like hard at things
we'll like have projects and all this
but we don't want to feel like all of
the responsibility is on us and if
shit's going south like we have to be
the one to make decisions and do
everything like that's so stressful well
you know what um when i left
i called my grandma i was like uh i
think i gotta get divorced and she was
like do it while you young while you
young well you take the dogs
but you know that's the thing about it
it would be different i would be
irresponsible if i had children with him
and then i left because it's not about
me anymore it's about them like if we
like if as long as we're not
you know gonna be like knocking heads
all the time it's like i made my bed i
gotta lay in it i know some women that
won't even do that well that's that's
being like that's not what i always say
once you have kids it's not about you
anymore yeah so that then like that's
but she got out before she had kids yeah
okay you know it's not men can get
divorced but women can't but like you
know the other thing is too is uh like
women are kind of brainwashed to think
that they need a lawyer now once they
find out and they go out with power
that's different but i thought i needed
a lawyer i found out i could get
divorced for 200 bucks i was like
what like this is new information has it
always been this way has it always been
this way and you don't even need to take
the guy to court that's why like i think
women should have more ethical divorces
more than anything because like if you
have some smart girlfriends do you want
to be friends with someone they're the
father of their children that's the
thing like why do you deserve half his
[ __ ] like half of him why why why and
why do you need to keep does he need to
keep paying you for the kids if you're
leaving like get a job
these hoes are lazy like i cannot i hate
lazy like i just that it irks me to
myself i don't care what you work hard
at i don't care if it's your marriage
yeah i don't care if it's your kids but
these hoes just want to do nothing and
they want to live off of their
ex-husbands and so now these men are
forced to pay for them
and they don't even get sex out of the
deal they don't even get sex that's
worse oh my gosh do you know like
they're like paying for the average sex
they didn't have in their last marriage
yeah it honestly breaks my heart because
a lot of these guys like they don't know
why their wife stopped sleeping with
them like they're really confused and it
keeps them up at night and they keep
thinking about how they can make it
better but it's like you know
unfortunately she didn't marry her first
choice and that that's like that's not a
fun conversation to have but i think too
like you know it like set him free set
that man free don't steal his stuff
but let him be single so he can find
somebody who likes him that's what yeah
yeah
leave your if you don't love your
husband leave him don't take half his
stuff and let us date him
um
okay
oh my gosh this is funny you dated a
toxic boyfriend for two years not two
years one and to be fair yeah it is a
red flag what the [ __ ]
like what the this is the thing like
everyone's like oh like every person has
red flags oh yeah and this is the thing
yeah vet the girls you're dating vet
them like you your ex marriage that's a
red flag oh yeah and yeah it's up to
your discernment as a dude to decide
what you want to deal with and don't
want to deal with yeah yeah so you know
what um i always forget this part of it
too so i got married because i was in
the military we were dual military so i
only knew him for three weeks but i like
i say this a lot i like to live high
risk high reward now it did last five
years but it's like what am i supposed
to do like it wasn't me like i had no
idea that this could happen
three weeks three weeks like i'm not
surprised
i'm not surprised
i don't even know that three weeks three
weeks
god damn oh my god
this is a fun uber ride this is i'm
trying to think three weeks
yeah i feel like i would do that too i'm
gonna be honest i was thinking i was
like i would be the type of [ __ ] to get
married at a reality tv show
like i like i just could see it
i just like literally could see myself
doing that i'm not saying that's a smart
thing to do i just i wouldn't put it
i feel like with certain guys
like if your interest is high enough so
what were you that into him was that it
like were you just so no um so i can
explain i didn't know that genuine
desire was a thing right i thought like
you just pick a guy and that's it that
was all you had to do is choose one
well you know uh so
like i said genuine desire wasn't there
at all from the beginning but i'm like
well he seems like a nice gentleman i'm
like surely like i will marry the nice
guy that's why people say like nice guys
finish last because it's true like i
didn't even know what i was doing but
here's the thing though is like i i was
20 the first time i got married that's
why i don't feel bad like the manosphere
can be mad but it's like you know like
you can't even get a woman in your bed
like you know what i'm saying like
but uh but yeah
coming from my situation that was a
really good decision coming from my
family and my background and the
toxicity that i grew up with i was like
well yeah this is a step up and it was
but it sucks that in order for me to
have to be the wife that i am now that i
had to have a starter marriage because i
don't feel good wasting that man's time
but you know it was like for sure a
character building experience
the i had not know three weeks you know
i would do it too though oh yeah yeah
well we if we didn't if we didn't get
married we weren't going to be able to
live together oh yeah yeah so i mean
people in the military get buried that's
why yeah that's why they do so i i
figured if it didn't work out that i was
going to get an annulment
yeah like i wasn't even really like
trying to see that thing through i was
like let me roll the dice like i'd
rather find out than not you know oh my
god
okay okay so they want to know what
decisions make women stress for for me
i would say the answer to this is it's
not about like what decisions make up
stress it's about your ability to make
decisions and figure it out like it's
more like having that skill set
because
like like i think like my dad right
that's the guy i look up to admire more
than anyone else in my life and i just
know
that
if if we have a decision like maybe on a
trip or something yeah we have to do
something or make a decision like i know
that he'll figure it out and even if
something goes wrong like he'll he'll
figure it out yeah and having that trust
in a dude like even if [ __ ] goes wrong
or maybe doesn't go like yeah but like
it's like when you're with a guy that's
so incompetent that you're just like
like you feel like you're doing
everything like that's what's
frustrating as a woman woman yeah so
date dumber girls
yeah i would say that that's something
that i really like about my husband that
i didn't have exposure to is just like
that constant leadership and like you
know ish does hit the fan he's like all
right that's what we're gonna do and
like okay thank you because i was like
really freaking out and like i didn't
have time for this and you know i was
getting stressed yeah yeah it's
typically like a good outcome too that's
like uh women talk about submission and
it's like if you had a good competent
leader would you really argue with that
like this man is doing fabulous like yes
i'm gonna make you the pancakes and the
bacon like what's the question what's
the question what's that
how do you like your french toast right
is it steak medium rare i can't cook but
i'll learn i'll learn
[Laughter]
oh man oh but
that's like i think as a guy like you
should practice being able to make
decisions so if maybe you're not like a
natural born leader like put yourself in
situations where you can lead like
smaller rooms so you can at least get
practice in in making decisions and
making them quick because the thing that
makes a good leader is they might not
make the right decision but they look at
the pros and cons and they make one
quick and fast and they don't like dwell
and be indecisive like that that's how
one woman moves yeah like we're like oh
i don't know which way to i don't know
where i want to
that's a female trait yeah and so when
you guys do that it's like we're like
stop being a [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
energy yeah yeah no i i definitely agree
and it's like that that's
that is definitely what makes a woman
stressful because it starts off like
minor right you're like oh you know well
i i'm an i'm an adult like yeah i'll
make a couple of decisions but like
three months goes by find yourself
making more make it more make it more he
starts doing less you start making up
for the jab start making up for the gap
you keep doing it doing it doing it all
sudden you're leading the relationship
and you're looking at him like sir did
you swindle me did you swindle me give
me back my gear give me back my use
where are my eggs
they're drying up as we speak
because we're taking so much time making
these goddamn decisions
and so when you like like a lot of times
guys want to like harp on girls for
leaving and i'm with you guys like i 100
agree like girls get married and they
want the resources from the guy they
want the attention from the guy they
want the kids from the guy and but a lot
of times you guys allow your woman to
like walk all over you and you allow her
to make all the decisions in the
relationship and while i don't condone
that like i don't know girl likes like
we don't like other girls that are ball
busters but you guys shouldn't let girls
do that and
every girl i know that's like that when
i talk to them like one-on-one
off-camera they're like oh no like i
like a guy who doesn't put up with me
yeah they all say that yeah they all say
that like even even feminists like
traditionally masculine men you know
like
they just have a tendency to be covert
about it whereas like conservative women
like we're over we're like yeah
absolutely you know what i expect i
expect you to be the primary breadwinner
unless you know like something also
happens for me an entrepreneurial
amazing way i also expect for you to
lead me and protect me questions
comments concerns the house will be
spotless thank you sir and i'm sorry no
no traditionally masculine guy is
arguing about who's paying on the first
date
i'm sorry oh yeah they're not they're
not tripping over the like like and
honestly most girls that they're like
like wholesome women yeah they're not
they're not they don't need a super
expensive first date no no it's like oh
if
anyone's pearl said she'll love you if
you take her to chipotle that should be
your dating show
it's like a shot at pearl oh my god
a shout out pearl can you get her order
right you get a date
that's funny like chipotle in my living
room i think i think that dating would
be too different from my channel so i
think if i did that because i've thought
about doing a dating show yeah no i
don't know if i'd have time to run it
but maybe a different like girl but
that's a good idea like chipotle dates
i'm into it i'm into it let's see what
else we got here
um
feminists want a masculine man they can
change that's true
i like brandon's question why are women
even inclined to walk all over someone
she supposedly
loves oh i know okay go ahead go ahead
yeah so here's the thing about it and i
think women do this subconsciously i
think it's like a hindbrain thing if you
as a man can't stand up to me as your
woman then how are you going to protect
me against the world right so if you
fold under me my pressure i'm like all
right well if anything ever happens like
i'm certainly not calling you like i'm
gonna have to call my brother or my
father because you suck well and it's
the same thing with like guys we can't
trust a guy that won't tell us the truth
so when you guys are like catering and
pandering to women and like telling us
what we want to hear like it makes us
hate you oh yeah like like it drives me
nuts when i just see a animal guys come
on my show and we're having a
conversation i know what they're trying
to say i'm like just say it like be a
man yeah like just say it like hold on
all these poses out don't you're gonna
make me do it
and and they'll be like oh it's
different from mandela but if you're a
masculine man you don't care
like that's that's just like who you are
you're not you're not catering to these
hoes yeah like stop catering to these
hoes and the thing about it is too is
like let's say you're that kind of guy
like you have opinions your principal
then you stand by them and you don't
care and you don't make excuses for it
and you don't apologize either if women
ever complain about you like let's say
you know you're like oh man this chick
ashley really don't like me everybody
says she's complaining about me all the
time yeah she's low-key feeling you she
low-key feeling if a woman has time to
talk about you for an hour sir sir she's
digging you
oh that is
that is so true right any man that like
oh my gosh any man i've ever complained
about long term i was feeling him yeah
yeah but you hate that you're feeling it
yeah that's why you're like i'm so
[Laughter]
[Music]
and this is what
and this is what guys like don't
understand and
like we
i get so irritated with guys that are
just like like can't say what they mean
it's so frustrating if you don't know
how to do it practice practice and spa
yeah i mean i would say that and the
thing about it is like you know modern
women these days we don't got a problem
being opinionated we might not do it to
your face but we will put you on tick
tock we will put you on tickets but
we're doing it
like fight fire
yeah let's let's talk about these hoes
um i wonder what oh
what my mac and cheese are you do you
make mac and cheese no i i make mac and
cheese on thanksgivings only because you
know
my husband he he's got like specific
things about his diet that he's into so
he doesn't do the whole greasy carb
thing very often but the key to good mac
and cheese is like real ingredients
don't do nothing out the box get fresh
pasta if you can if you can make your
own pasta even better and get fresh
cheeses like grate it yourself that's
what i'm saying like women be too lazy
to even make a good meal i'm gonna even
make a good meal you can't
cheese grater it's a cheese grater it's
not so like i'm just so tired of these
lazy like they just don't want to do
anything they don't want to learn any
skill i don't want like they act like
they act like housewives in the 1950s
for like whatever the hell housewives
were like
our machines are better it's so much
easier now i got an air fryer and a
roomba and an electric shower scrubber
that's what i said we fumbled the bag
because before before they used to no no
they used to have to hand wash clothes
they just have to hand wash the dishes
we're back yay okay i'm sorry guys i'm
sorry hold on hold on hold on we're
struggle busting here yeah and you know
what think about it like this is some
real exclusive content like yeah where
else do you get honest women like this
in the middle of an uber yeah two two
hour long uber this is content yeah i'm
sorry guys i don't know my phone was
like glitching it was so glitching it
happened um let's look at the comments
last thing you be here mama susan don't
like this oh they think that's susan
what susan wozniak
independent woman boss babe oh god it
wasn't like the last thing we were
talking about was the automation in the
machines yeah like being also in the
1950s
now it's so much like you're telling me
that you can't check this out even if
like
what a lot of
people don't know is how good like
is when you cook it though right so like
no seasonings and i i had to like find
this out was so sensitive to food so i
just like put salt on me throw it in the
air fryer come out and i'm like okay
that's my meal coming to find out
chicken wings are amazing plain with
salt you mean to tell me thanks yeah so
you can't put the wings in the bowl
throw some salt in there and push the
push the power button on the airfryer
how hard is that and then they're like
i don't i can't serve a man oh my gosh
okay well okay becky um
i don't get it women want to be wise
just to be like sidekicks like or like
companionship they say i'm like
i've heard from women that are very
successful they outsource everything
except for you know the bedroom fun
that's probably the only thing that they
don't outsource but like the cooking the
cleaning and the raising kids i'm like
why did you even bother getting married
why did you even bother like what's the
point to be like besties you my best
friend
okay um they want to know what what do
you think of this conversation they want
to know what the uber driver thinks
oh what do you think about our
conversation sir
yeah
thank you he says it's very good it says
very good
yeah
do you do you have daughters sons
yep yeah or how many kids do you have
i have one
one daughter does she does she agree
with this stuff or no would she hate it
she agrees oh well yeah because she has
a father
[Laughter]
yes and it's like
it's like feminism i think has ruined
women today because
because it has told us it's told us go
sleep around okay like be a hoe oh and
then you'll like it right
you won't be like a drunk mess who's
like upset all the time right yeah
you're gonna have a great time like this
is the cycle this is the these hoes go
through college this is like college
early twenties it goes like this it's
like
um i start to sleep with the chad right
the chad doesn't want you so like pass
smash pass onto the next cry over the
chat go to the parties get drunk then
like cry in the bathroom over it to feel
better you sleep with the next chad
who does the same thing
um and then like it's just a continual
cycle and feminism says yeah instead of
finding a husband that loves you go get
ran through by the college football
basketball and hockey team okay yeah
it's like i don't i don't feel bad for
sorority girls like the hot ones that
get played i'm like man
you shouldn't learn by the fifth one
like by the fifth one i would have been
like you know what like these guys don't
want to hang out the day after maybe i
should pick another one maybe it also
could be who you are as a person right
maybe it's you it could be your
personality i know it i can't i can't
i'm aging like holly holm is that a
valley home no holly holm i think is a
was a fighter she was like a white woman
fighter so he called you a boxer a boxer
yeah i can't i just can't decide should
i be offended or is it a compliment it's
a stranger on the internet who cares
like their name is is brick mac i just
want to know i just want to know who
holly holm is she yeah she was a fighter
i'll pull up a picture let me see let me
see it could go either way guys drop
some questions in the chat guys
answer them like whatever you've been
wanting to know about women like we're
here for it yeah
here for it
so what do you like what do you struggle
with when you're friends with a woman
and she's addicted to attention
but i hate it i hate i can't be friends
with a woman like that god i mean it's
like
because you love them and you care about
them on some level you think they're
like a nice person but like
okay i know the manosphere wants you to
like
always um let me let me just stop really
quick ali's trending on twitter for
talking about being a housewife just
this person keeps putting that in the
chat but yeah okay so it's like you love
them and you want what's best for them
but like when they're just obsessed with
guys and it's just so frustrating
because i'm all about like submitting to
a man but like submit to a man that
deserves it yeah all your energy on a
guy that deserves it not only doesn't
care about you
so it's like
like and and i understand like you know
you can people make mistakes but it's
like if you keep doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
again it's like i can't feel bad for you
anymore i really can't oh my gosh and
it's like
it's weird to watch women constantly
chase men that are bad for them now i
know like rollo can explain this for for
hours upon hours probably he's probably
got like 100 hours of content on this
but as a woman it doesn't make me want
to be friends with you because i always
have problems and they're the same women
to come to me about their relationship
constantly crying and complaining and
then going back to him and it's like
also if you ever held her accountable
for it your friendship would be over no
she's like wasting all of your time well
and that's the thing like i'm most
thankful when i was in a relationship i
shouldn't have been like i don't act
like i'm better than these women you
know i mean like like everyone has their
moments but i was lucky to have people
that held me accountable when they're
like look it
she's kind of hot i'm not even back
okay
yeah but like you're thankful for the
people that'll tell you the truth like
when i was in a bad relationship like my
dad literally said to me he said do you
like torture because you literally keep
going back to the same guy that like and
it keeps not working out for you and
that was one of the things that made me
leave angry and and it's like you have
to be so it's like hard because you want
to be honest with these girls but they
get so mad at you when you are every
time every time like it's to the point
where if i get a good girlfriend i feel
like i can't even tell her stuff so
somebody ah i don't want to cover that
okay where's the where's the
that one so like larry this girl's latin
she's talking about wings with just salt
and sufficient seasoning what no like
there was a time in my life where for
real i ate like meat and salt every day
it was like for 90 days and then like
that was like majority of my diet was
still meat and salt because i had like
this weird food intolerance problem so
no like i seasoned my husband's food
like i promise i am not doing that white
man dirty like i'm latina i can do it
okay um okay should men be able to opt
out of fatherhood i think they should i
think i think if girls if no no actually
i don't think they should because i
don't i think we should get rid of like
the child support system yeah and i and
because i like think women should be
held accountable like if you pick a guy
that's a bomb and like doesn't want to
be in there like pick better okay like
pick better and and i understand like
sometimes like that might not work out
but that's where your family comes in
it's not the government's job to come
bail you out because you can't pick a
man like you make poor just like that's
not why is that what do i have to pay as
a taxpayer for your like or why does he
why why
does the government have to come in
between yeah yeah and i've seen like the
most loser like loser biz natchez who
like they got pregnant from a one-night
stand on two separate occasions like
years apart and then they're like quick
to put the man on child support i'm like
and that's why you guys got to be
careful there's women out there ready to
poach you like please wrap it up because
that kid like he his dad never wanted
him to be there in the first place but
because you want to be a selfish woman
and you can't get a man in the long term
like i can't get a man but i can have a
baby that doesn't make sense to me also
if it's going to be her body her choice
like how about his wallet his choice
yeah his wallet yeah yes like because
sperm jacking is not illegal it should
be well
yes
and and
if a woman okay what i don't think
abortion should be legal at all like if
it was up to me if this is pearl's world
like a pearl for president like
it would just be illegal but
if we're we're in a society where
abortion is legal so if a girl can opt
out of being a mom why can't the dad opt
out of being a dad like just let's let's
let's go for equality hold up hold up
what about the dusty moms that like give
up custody of their kids like don't
nobody really call that woman out like
you see her at thanksgiving you'd be
like man
man but let her have been a man
different story different story but if
he's a woman she's going through some
things right now oh she's she's having
such a hard time she's finding herself
finding herself no
get out of here
no
pearl alley2024
we might let's go
let's go
oh gosh oh okay okay um ali how do you
feel about going viral how is the
backlash also real quick thank you for
the twenty dollar
super chat from corty jones guys these
super chats really help like support the
channel all the money it goes towards
like new
equipment and i'm also trying to hire
people right now yeah so
really appreciate you guys sending the
super chats i don't want you to feel
like it's not appreciated oh yeah yeah
definitely even if it's two bucks right
because like that to that for youtube is
engagement so even if you're like you
know what i ain't got it pearl but i
want to help you out with the algorithm
like two dollars yeah
if you can't super chat like the video
because that also really helps with the
algorithm it does it does so what was
the question so how do you feel about
going viral and how has the backlash
back oh my gosh um she loves it she's
excited no no no i like it but i think
it really is like a sign of the times
okay like that how how do you go viral
for being a happy stay-at-home wife and
i think it might have been because i
talk about submission or that my ring is
big but that's how bad things are that's
how bad the dating market is is that
like that's like shocking stunning and
brave
it shouldn't be and like people talking
about like oh you know feminism is about
choice like meanwhile feminists straight
up ish on housewives and they don't even
know that they're doing it because i see
the pictures or like the artwork that
they put out there the content they put
out there i'm like no you hating on it
and so it's like if housewives weren't
under attack then why did i go viral
why yeah
no exactly and that's the thing they'll
act like listen it's about choice but
when you say oh i like to submit to my
man i like to let him be the leader in
the house i like to do this i like to do
that it's like they're like well
i find this problematic
they'd be the same women that are like
the worst managers and supervisors
and like honestly like guys i i am a
business like i own a business i i work
a lot like you know me i like to work i
work hard at things but the thing is
like like i as a woman can say we are
not as good at managing people we're not
like it is hard for us because we're
more agreeable like it is very hard for
me to like tell someone they're like
that that you're not like you're not
doing a good job this is what you need
to
do better like
if i had it my way like i would have
someone else like run that part and i
could just like show up and do the
content yeah but
uh yeah oh hi sarah thank you you've
been doing such a good job on the on the
show sorry is the guy that's been
hosting oh yeah yeah i know i keep up
shout out to sarah
um how do i find this viral video go to
my tic toc it's just pearly things um
you'll have to scroll a couple videos
down but it's got 1.4 million views um
thank you again for the soup chat
loyalty stability respectable honorable
most men are not looking for our
most men not looking for a house cleaner
not a cook
um
uh he's saying oh he's saying like
that's like okay if you if you don't if
you're not like the the cleanest and
it's okay if you're not like a chef yeah
i understand like my thing is like
making a sandwich is easy sis i'm
telling you and they like it i thought i
thought it was weird i was like the man
is always talking about serving your man
making him a meal
and i'm like what is this i'm like okay
all right i'm gonna do it for two weeks
yo the man became so nice so cuddly so
warm i was like this stuff works well
and and this is the thing i think guys
just want a bit of tries yeah they just
don't feel like you care yeah i don't
even think it's about like being like i
think guys are willing to put up with a
lot like it you don't have to have the
perfect body you don't have to be like
the perfect like you don't have to be a
perfect cook you don't have to be great
at cleaning like you just have to try
and he has to like feel like you're
trying and like respecting him along the
way and that's how you that's how you
set yourself apart from other women in
the dating market too like women they
hear about competition and they still
like oh how dare you make me compete
like how many men you got competing for
you right now where's your phone show me
your phone
show me your phone talking about
competition is bad but if you want to
i'm telling you it's not hard uh you
know
cheat codes right like women if you're
watching apparently men love when women
wear dresses i don't know why i started
asking husbands what is your favorite
outfit that their their wives wear and
they they start off with a birthday suit
and i'm like no like actual clothes
though they all say dresses that they
like it and that it's flowy and that
it's fun and that it's feminine i don't
know so also like not that hard to do
something nice with your hair i'm not
saying you have to heat treat it but
putting a little bit of cream in there
so it's moisturized that'll set you
apart from like some fried woman who
looks like she's been like baking in the
sun like spongebob and patrick that's
okay but
other things you can do is like you know
complimentary jewelry it depends on the
kind of feminine woman that you want to
be but that's like that's appearance you
also have to work on your personality
too like that's important but if you
want to get you know caught off
like
a man
i look around you american american
women are like oh like i'm gonna travel
and find a man i'm like bam and he's
gonna want you there oh no oh no no
actually maybe in england i think girls
get a point in england
i think if six becomes an eight in
england i'm not even gonna lie to you um
i'm sorry so it's good to see you're
enjoying yourself probably your show is
mine now hey guys guys put a one in the
chat if you want sarah to be a weekly
guest or if you want to be you want him
to host a weekly show
um okay let's see sundresses are
dangerous
what
like explain that one oh
have i i've never really seen patrice
o'neill have you oh yeah patrice
o'neill's hilarious so he's uh he was a
big uh stand-up comic he was black
obviously patrice
right right yeah and he he would talk
about female nature so even though he
was like this big obese dude like he had
game he would get women all the time and
he had a call and talk show and one of
the funniest videos he ever had was like
this wife called in she was like you are
full of ish you're full of ish like kind
of just being absolutely rude and he was
like i can only imagine
how you talk to your husband and he was
like what does your husband do and she
was like he's a truck driver he's like
perfect just the right job where he
works six days a week away from you away
from you
oh my god yeah
he was great yeah shout out to him he's
like one of the og godfathers oh yeah i
remember before we cut off earlier what
i was going to say is like women look at
me like i got a tinfoil hat when i say
this if you were a business and you
wanted to double your income by doubling
your customers
like you would you would probably do
that right so the united states
government was a business you don't
think they somehow benefit by like
making women
stay in the workforce out in necessity
and like incentivize for men to be out
of the homes like you don't think that
maybe feminism is kind of like you know
it's a little bit big picture it's a
little bit big picture because they want
me to work they want my money because if
i'm only depending on my husband for
financially which i don't i also work i
know the internet thinks that i don't do
anything but you know if it's only him
that that's a single single income
that's taxable so it's like these people
are greedy they want you working in the
factory they want they want everything
yeah it's like
i've said this so many times i'm just so
tired of being like these [ __ ] are
lazy they are lazy like and here's like
guys just want a girl that tries it's
not even hard to try no it's not that
hard and it's okay it's okay to know
where like like i'll give you guys an
example i don't know if you've noticed
what's less on the channel
right no no because like like honestly
being a girl and that [ __ ] like doesn't
let me i've always been a tomboy but
it's okay to like know that you're bad
at something and just try like who can
then girls will always be like oh like i
don't want to do it badly like do [ __ ]
badly like do [ __ ] badly until you're
good at it like if you're not a good
cook cook badly till you're a good cook
like you can you can literally do
anything that you set your mind to if
you work at something for two three
years like you're gonna be above
probably eighty percent of people
because eighty percent of people aren't
gonna try it's not even hard i've had my
youtube channel for nine months and
everybody's like it's really weird how
many subs you have i don't do youtube
like i'm still new so i'm like i am
successful i was like oh you know like
me because i put in some effort i don't
know you know a lot of channels that
don't take off and i see people complain
about it i'm like it's cause your
content is trash like the internet is so
big there's 7.67 billion people on this
planet if you can't get subs that's a
you problem that's not a people problem
it's a you thing it's it's you it's you
and
you've been have you been burned by
female entrepreneurs i've wasted like
probably six hundred dollars on female
entrepreneurs i won't even do it anymore
like now i have to ask my husband before
because i'm nice i'm like oh i want to
buy this he's like no you love it you'd
let these hoes take your money well so
you can't buy from home you know like no
no look at me yeah we can't buy from
hoes well are they hoes so what i was
doing research like for feminine
products right the last thing you bought
we talked about
what's the last thing i bought i don't
know
you tell me
i don't know i don't know
pearl's bad look at me look at me we
can't buy from hoes that's true
yeah yeah that's my fault
you know what but people would call me
sexist for saying that male
entrepreneurs do it better i'm sorry but
we don't like most of us because we get
and like to be honest most of the good
female entrepreneurs entrepreneurs have
men behind us
yeah i have a male youtube manager that
i take advice from um my thumbnail guy
is a dude like the dude that's running
my show right now is a dude like
like my dad is a a dude and that's who i
get a lot of advice from the show like
every person i go to four things for my
show is a man
and
that's and i know that like and i think
the girls that understand that about
women is that like sometimes we're
chemically different every single day
yeah so we get more emotional than guys
so
like it's pretty wise to use guys to
help you make your decisions i'm not
some guys i'm not going to trust to do
[ __ ] yeah absolutely it's not like
somebody dollar bombs yeah but a guy
that's like competent like why would you
not ask his opinion on things like mine
my dad's like the most successful person
i know why would i not ask him opinion
his opinion on [ __ ] i was just at like a
get-together the other day yeah i spent
like what two hours talking to this guy
about youtube yeah like and that's the
thing like female entrepreneurs there's
just not many that i really want to talk
to for that long i know they just want
to be like pretty and that's it and i'm
like uh
that's that it gets oh and oh you know
what let's talk about this you are not
an entrepreneur if you do only fans i do
not respect no i don't respect any girl
that makes her money through your looks
and your looks alone it's okay to use it
to supplement [ __ ] like we'd be smiling
for thumbnails yeah i'm not sticking my
ass or my tits out like i don't do that
you know i'll say like
but
what i'm not gonna do is give you give
girls the validation of being like oh
you're a successful entrepreneur when
all you're doing is taking your clothes
off on the internet that's all you're
doing becky that's it you're not you're
not smart you're not and the thing is
you're lazy because you are not
interesting enough to make an audience
offer your personality can i say this
can i say this i wanted to find out
about only fans right because i'm like
what is all this this thing that women
are doing cause i'm nosy so i was like
going in i'm like all right i'm gonna
pay for this one let me go look yo
they're so lazy they're only fans
content isn't even good it's not even
good
hey you want only fans and you can't
even put your heart into it
you know like you you have like
fractured the dating market for yourself
forever you can't even try with that you
can't like where's the lighting
all right that'd be so funny critiquing
women's only that would be great patreon
i'm just saying if you're gonna if
you're gonna be an only if you're gonna
be an only fans model put your heart
into it like yeah get the outfits
nina unrated you know her yeah yeah
she's like the best stripper with a work
ethic she puts so much effort into being
absolutely presentable that's true and
she just you know and you know what i
like about her she accepts the
consequence yes she doesn't [ __ ] and
complain she's like yeah i was a hoe i
am a hoe these are the consequences of
being how i'm gonna keep being at home
but she doesn't [ __ ] about it no she
didn't she doesn't complain about it she
just says i was a hoe these are the
consequences whatever yeah i respect
them more than these hoes that are gonna
shame men and call them insecure for not
wanting a girl that's been ran through
by the entire college football
basketball hockey team wait wait wait no
dude what's a girl that everyone has had
wait real talk real talk do you know at
least one woman that has slept with most
of a team yes oh my gosh yes
that's so bad she's done forever you're
like how are you an alpha widow seven
times
was it like uh like a giga widow
yeah well i mean but the thing is these
hoes aren't dumb because they just move
they just move
what do you mean oh they get to leave
their whole path behind yeah they just
move like colleges like this is what i
said i don't i don't really think men
pick to be honest i don't think men pick
prudes we were talking about a dinner i
think a lot of times hoes get like wifed
up faster than prunes i really do i
really do but the difference is i think
that hoes get divorced because the thing
is when you're when you're a hoe it's
not you you are like damaging your
dating prospects like that does happen
but i think i've asked so many guys this
question and i always say like would you
rather have had a girl has slept with 20
dudes okay or one dude you know and so
that says to me like it's not about the
purity it's about like men knowing about
it do you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
it's i think it's mostly
more so right and so that tells me right
so where was i going with this so but i
think the damage you know no no the
damage that actually happens
is is
to the girl's head
because she she'll want to leave the
marriage because she can't compare her
husband to them
like like i do think like sleeping
around is damaging but i i think most of
those girls still get picked and they
still get married and some and sometimes
by quality guys because they're blue
pill and they're young right and they
don't know any better they think they
can change the girl like to me i think
most girls if they're hot enough like
honestly like i'm just being real i
think a lot of them do and can get away
with it but the damage is to yourself
because in the future you will compare
every single guy like that you date to
the to the previous guys and if you
[ __ ] like oh gosh i shouldn't say i'm
sorry i don't want to get my life
demonetized but but if you've screwed
like 50 dudes like how is your husband
gonna be the best one and she's gonna
feel like she's settled and that's like
that's why they leave and
so like i think girls get like get away
with on paper yeah you know like they
get away with it on paper but the thing
is like i've talked to older people and
they're like yeah the hoes always get
divorced yeah so yeah like you might get
away with it for now like there might be
no consequences now but you wait in 20
years because you're not gonna be
satisfied and you're addicted to that
life like like if you're like i just
feel like over a certain age like you
shouldn't be like out of the club's
partying and doing all that stuff
through your whole 20 years because
remember the habits you make today like
that is who you become yeah you are your
habits so if every weekend you are going
out to the bars and you're binge
drinking and doing all that stuff like
that is who you are yeah so if you if
that's what you're gonna practice from
18 to 30 like that that's your habits
that's what you do all the time like
that that's who you become and you're
gonna be addicted to that life because
that [ __ ] is fun it's fun like it's like
no it's serious it's almost dying all
the time yeah right you know i'm saying
like like the like doing that like
living this exciting exhilarating life
like that that's fine but if you it's
like it's like getting drunk like that's
fun but if you become addicted to it
like there's so many consequences yeah
and if you do it for a decade of your
life like that's gonna have
ramifications on the rest of your life
let me ask you this
because i think this is weird i i see
single mothers so i we're millennials i
am i'm 27. i have women in my cohort
that like they're single mothers and
they're going to music festivals yeah i
don't think that's appropriate no
because like what like your child is
with like a sitter because you couldn't
even keep the dad and it's like these
are the same women that filed in the
first place i had a girlfriend i had
suspected she was crazy for a long time
and then one day i started talking to
her and i was like so what what did
happen to your first husband she said
that she cheated on him but she cheated
on him with a narcissist got pregnant
two times like those kids are
traumatized everyone's traumatized come
to find out like she's regretted it the
whole time so she fo mode and like now
there's like three little boys that have
to deal with that
and that's crazy
like like it baffles me how selfish yeah
like how selfish some of these women are
because i'm sorry like why are you on
the weekends going to these festivals
like you're just like i'm 25. i don't i
don't i don't even go to these festivals
i think i'm too old for this [ __ ] that's
something you do when you're like 18 19
20. i don't even like going to bars how
old were you when you stopped going to
bars i know you vlogged it sometimes but
like for yourself like
i mean i'll go every like couple of
months like
like now
like i'll go out a couple times a year
but consistently like at 21 22 i was i
was like over it
because i i drank like you know you go
out in college sure but after that i'm
like i'm trying to start a business i'm
trying to get [ __ ] done yeah it's true
let's see what we got here good morning
archer
mojado says stop mommy saw mommy's in
that club she's gonna need a babysitter
call a babysitter she's gonna need a
babysitter uh all right we had a crew
bicycle wow thanks mott that was mary
mary a security guard the union and
security don't interact so he didn't
know her pass oh my gosh that's so bad
if like your man's co-workers know that
you're a 304. oh no no
oh no critique only fans somebody said
that's a good idea thank you
she got pregnant she gonna need a
babysitter well yeah that's that's the
thing like
i i genuinely think like men will talk
this big game oh i would never date a
girl that did this this this and this
and i'm like
i i'm not trying to be an [ __ ] but i
see who like even though like high value
men are doing it yeah like even and i'm
like okay
she might say that but i like girls we
know
we know like we know more than you guys
know like which girls have done [ __ ]
like which girls haven't like because
there's inconsistencies in girls stories
and you can just like the way they like
girls just pick up on this [ __ ] and so
like or they'll flirt with like the
ugliest dudes just for the attention
because you know she's not taking him
seriously do you see it in real time
you're like he's like he's homeless why
are you shaking your breath at home what
is that for why are you shaking the
tatas for the homeless man yeah and we
we pick up on that like faster than guys
so we see you guys you guys still wife
up hoes like you guys do it all the time
you i think maybe you don't aren't aware
to the extent right and and they'll say
it's like the blue pill guys but
honestly i see a lot of red pill guys do
it too yeah like every dude every young
dude is red pilled until he gets the
girlfriend after the red pills back to
the blue yeah but that's why they're so
mad it's kind of like we're so mad when
like we say like oh he's an [ __ ]
it's like the same thing like they're so
mad at these hoes because they love them
they've been falling in love with them
and and like you know
i think sometimes like
it just is what it is but the thing is
like the issue is the hose
it damages themselves like they're
really hurting themselves for later yeah
like because they get away with it but
only for so long until you're addicted
to that life and you just can't
like that's like genuinely that's part
of the reason i stopped drinking was
because i was just like i don't want
that to become who i am as a person and
the longer like it's kind of weird
because like the longer you go without
drinking it's just like it becomes
easier and even easier of course
um let's see everybody like selena
powell like she's like i have an
epiphany i want to get serious and she's
like trying to like what she was trying
to see with somebody to get all her only
fans videos down like baby girl like
people forget the internet doesn't the
internet doesn't oh also
what's up with women who are moms that
have only fans and you ask them like
what happens if your kid finds it and
they're like oh like i'll cross that
bridge when i get there like ma'am like
you're so like off himself like
you're selfish that's what i did you are
so like i
i okay this is unpopular opinion that i
have in the manuscript i think it's
selfish for a guy to cheat when he has a
family if that's not the arrangement
with his wife yeah because like when
you're putting your family at risk and
two you're putting your wife at risk for
getting an std i agree so i like you can
get you can get an std
sorry sorry guys we're in and out we're
back
okay hold on real quick ah the guy that
says like who's driving like they
probably think we're in a tesla we're
wearing an uber yeah we're at uber okay
selfish women booty pics want kids oh
but yeah but i'm saying like you're
selfish because you're putting me me me
me me above the family and when when you
have a family it is not about you
anymore your happiness becomes something
yeah it's the family and i just think we
have so many people that are so goddamn
selfish and like they were just
raised in this environment where it's
like me me me first me me me first yeah
and like you don't think of anyone else
and i part of it i think is people are
having less and less kids well i think
that's why they're having less lessons
because we got modern women we got
modern men too like if you're talking to
a man who's 30 like are you ready for
kids like no not right now you know like
i'm trying to get set up and you're like
looking at him like like so like how
long have you been trying to get set up
like sir you are 30 years old that's the
wall for men i call it the performance
wall you can still climb over it but if
you don't know what you're going to do
by 30 as a man you probably ain't ever
going to figure out like it's done so
yeah like it's like immature
selfish narcissistic young men and young
women in the dating market they're too
scared to have kids they're like oh i'm
worried about the carbon footprint i'm
like just say youtube like just say
selfish there's still like
and like these people like and that's
the thing like i think we have so many
only children or people who only have
like two kids in the house which isn't
bad if you rate like if you raise them
the right way but like honestly like in
my family like it was good to have
siblings because it humbles you because
you learn from a young age it ain't
really about you yeah like you you can't
be about you when you're 10 other people
to compete and that's what we're all
funny
because we all really wanted attention
nice
um
let's do other ones
you're dropping bombs on fresh and fit
hell yeah oh yeah i was dropping bombs
on fresh and fit i hope it was a good
episode i was trying to save that
educated woman she was nice like she
wasn't trying to swing on anybody so i
think if she met a masculine man i'll
talk about you penn on the fresher fit
panel i feel like if she met a masculine
man she'd probably take his lead he just
has to out earn her and she probably has
to work part time you know if a woman
refuses to sleep with her man he should
cheat okay
i think if you're a dude well i think if
you're like i've talked to guys where
they said that happened to them and they
said oh i i told her that this was gonna
happen yeah like be a man tell her tell
her what's up and you have to be willing
to walk away i think you know the issue
that they're probably gonna say is that
legally there's consequences and
ramifications if that happens yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying like so i i'm not
sure that men should cheat on their
wives because let her find out this can
be the first piece of evidence that she
uses in court in alimony like send some
smoke signals like i don't know what you
have to do to get with your sneaky link
but i don't think it's right for women
to like sequester a man to self-pleasure
for like the rest of the marriage like
that's crazy
i cannot believe that there are women
married right now they're like well i'm
not gonna sleep with him but i also like
he's not allowed to cheat on me like
ma'am what are you making he said like
what what do you think he's doing like
i can't like if you're torturing a guy
because guys are built like differently
than us i forgot what it is it's like
they have a 24-hour fertility clock or
something or whatever they have just had
like significantly higher amounts of
testosterone than us like 17 times yeah
yeah so like they just like have that
impulse to do it more we do too but it's
like cyclical and honestly like a lot of
guys are willing to like i think more
guys are willing to be monogamous than
the manosphere really like puts out yeah
like they'll say oh all guys would do
this if if they got the choice or
whatever but i'm like
there's a lot of guys i know that's just
their values yeah yeah so it's like like
we were around a lot of high
quote-unquote high-value men you know
like top of one percent earner some of
them i think but the thing about it is
like
the that they're the kind of guys that
women like claw themselves over but not
every woman actually wants to do that
like there comes a threshold for women
where this is what i've noticed is like
most women want to be wives absolutely
want to be wives but then if he earns
enough they're like you know what like
this is optional like i'm okay with it
we'll just be in a long-term
relationship like it's fine but that's
like a compromise that women make
because of the resources like some women
they really would rather share an alpha
than be saddled with a beta yeah that's
yeah that's that's so like i underst i
understand the women and i understand
those men and those men they just have
that leverage you know and like that's
not to say that there aren't wholesome
chads out there that are like loyal to
their wives and like go to the gym and
stuff like that i live in the midwest
like i know a couple of them like the
type of build your house for you but
it's like you know i can't judge
necessarily too hard on them that makes
sense because as much as i don't like it
there's a woman doing it like man i hate
what the man is right
yeah i mean i i'm all about like people
do without like don't let me tell you
how to live your life but i'll call you
out when you're on some [ __ ]
um five dollar super chat if another if
a your man asked you to source another
woman for him would you do it and i i
would not no
no no i don't think i would do that
either but i'm not sure that that's
necessarily what he would be interested
in although like you know i have like
make jokes about it in the past what are
your views on virginity on virginity
is a fetish because i know too many
virgin women that get done
they can't even get it on a date they're
attractive they can't even get on a date
because they're a virgin because the
young men that they're because they're
young the women are young yeah they're
going out with these young dudes and
they don't want to be saddled with that
responsibility so they'd rather like try
to get a 304 then like i don't know you
know take the v card and then date her
for three years like at least do her
some justice right but they're like ah i
don't know i don't know well it goes
back to the like i think there's a lack
of men with like masculinity yeah right
so i think we have a masculinity and
like crisis today so let's say there's
20 of the guys that like are above the
threshold of like attractiveness that
women want and maybe the masculinity of
responsibility what okay okay hold on
hold on i'll oliver biscuit let me ask
you this since it's bs have you ever
dated a virgin where's she at now
where's she at now wait they get
rejected
they get dusted the man yeah
yeah and i was older like i was halfway
through college which like most girls
would be losing their virginity in high
school yeah you know it's like i'm
telling you like
having that like thought like i would
tell guys i was a virgin and they'd be
like uh never mind
but to me
but but okay but here's the thing like
the guys that the virgins want right the
like the person and i know the guys were
like well why don't they just go for the
guys they're not attracted to it okay
okay so but they if they go for the guys
they want those guys if they're like hmm
let me wait for this girl or let me let
me deal with the girl that's going to
sleep with me sooner
like i'm just i want it quicker and this
is just what i've noticed so you guys
maybe i'm wrong but like
most guys i've noticed like if they can
get
a girl that's like like maybe not maybe
not a virgin but like more on the pure
side but it's going to sleep yeah a
little a little body count for sure yeah
but yeah a little bit sooner like
they'll take that over a virgin like
because they're like oh i don't want to
go through the trouble of like having to
marry this girl before i can like even
yeah it's a fetish and it's also a
pedestalization too because like men
that have access to a multitude of women
they're like okay like she's a virgin
it's like literally nothing special
like on to the next they're like oh okay
you know high body count yeah you know
she's not anything special because i
know how women really are it's usually
inexperienced men that go on and on and
on about virginia that's what i'm saying
like a virginity yeah i don't
and
you guys i don't enjoy this because i
genuinely feel like like like in my
heart of soul i i think like what are
they saying um
like men don't really want them oh oh
it's like it's the saddest thing in the
world because you know i have like these
nice girlfriends but explain to them why
most men just don't qualify because the
men that actually real deal want virgins
like they'll do the work to get one so
why don't most men qualify well well i
think partially like
the problem is a lot of the guys that
want virgins are like more beta because
i just think the alpha guys like have
like a sense of like sexuality to them
yeah yeah like that's just like part of
like that's probably like the high
testosterone
i think it's a young idea
and if men like really wanted birth like
if ben if in general like purity was you
know
hey guys again this isn't fun i don't
enjoy this because because
i i really like think the way it should
be is like people should wait till
they're married i think it's better that
way i think it's better for families but
if if it was true that the most like
that people valued virginity and purity
the same way we did like a hundred years
ago the men that are the most powerful
and have the most options and access and
all that stuff they would marry virgins
but you don't see that
yeah yeah like like like you don't you
just don't see that in date like
day-to-day life and it's sad
but
like
it's just typically the guys that want
virgins are the guys you don't want and
it's not like this isn't this isn't fun
guys and the guys said say they want
virgins like they don't
they don't actually do what it takes to
get one yeah it was it they say so it's
like it's like when women are like i
want a high value man but you know like
she's never going to be able to get one
so it's like a buffer so that instead of
going out and pursuing a man she could
actually get because that would mean
that she would get rejected let me just
say i want a high value man so i never
have to try it's the same thing let me
just say i want a virgin so i never have
to try that that's why that's why i'm
single guys i'm waiting for a virgin
like okay sir
do it do within
and this isn't like again guys this
isn't fun yeah i'm not trying to be mean
i'm not like saying oh i'm so happy that
like purity isn't what it used to be but
like
virgin girl
you like guys are impressed when you
tell them and they're like wow until you
say oh it's going to be at least six
months and they're like oh
i don't want it that bad yeah they say
that it's like
return or you say oh like we have to
wait until you're married to have sex
you're like i really don't want it that
bad yeah yeah
that's not valuable like we know it is
valuable it is important and it's
precious and women should guard it we
just didn't do it we didn't do it and
we're we're the good ones the good ones
and and you know like i genuinely wish i
did yes i i think i think it's better
that way and but
like i'm just telling you the i don't
think the demand for virgins is as much
as it used to be and i i also think a
guy like you don't have to be alpha
widow i think that guys once they get
over a certain threshold of
attractiveness like i think it's hard
for them to come down once they're used
to eight nines or tens like all the time
i think it's hard for those men to go
back to a six yeah cause they'd be like
damn that's what i'm worth and it's like
baby boy it is what you're worth yeah it
is what's your words and you know like
we don't think we're these awesome
amazing women like i you know i feel
regular specular yeah and my man okay
here's the funny thing like for example
everybody calls my man high value high
value y'all like we are not we are not
rich we are not wealthy we are regular
blue collar people living in the midwest
you know i don't understand we just have
youtube channels make a youtube channel
yeah corty jones we are living proof of
the
sean manifesto read it thank you so much
for the super chat all super chats guys
they really fun the channel like i swear
to god i i invest i reinvest all the
money you guys send me into the channel
um and i really want to take this money
and like hire people so really
appreciate it yeah you're employing
people capitalism um julian i've been
asking many times about your channel
sponsor cooking with chris and need more
information but there's no there's no
info on the link we'll find out um okay
did you look and if you go to my past
live streams the link should be there
um
but
i'm like surprised because basically the
man just makes you a customized meal
plan like you should
you should try it it actually helped me
lose a lot of weight um
wait waiting for verges these days is
just an excuse to not get married
ever yeah i mean that's that's true it's
like the female equivalent
um
let's see
the problem is f boys with literally
nothing going for them packing eight
inch daggers
um demand for virgins diminished you
realize these women aren't virgins
that's true
um
when the average age for marriage is
almost 30 waiting for marriage is not a
practical expectation yeah i mean look
at fair enough guys like i'm not again
i'm not saying this in a way that like
oh i'm happy this is how it is i'm just
telling you what i've seen yeah and if
you guys have seen different things like
you can let me know but but like talking
to guy friends like they just really
want a girl that hasn't slept with a lot
of people they know like that's the
biggest thing like they they can't she
can't have slept with a lot of people
they know and they have to interact with
and
yeah and like she used to be nice and
pretty
yeah yeah men have like really low
requirements for relationships that's
why when women are single i'm like
that's not that's not a man problem
that's like that's a you problem because
the supply is high and the demand is low
like there's tons of single men out
there there's a lot of them do you think
that women should be less hypergamous or
you think they're justified in it
because to be honest on your average guy
it is not like biologically attractive
so what do you think um i think women
should be hypergamous if they qualify
for it so if you're like if you're if
you're in the back like top 20 of shape
and like you you know how to cook and
you know how to like do these things and
you have like like i'm sorry if a girl's
at age she knows how to cook and she's
in shape like why would she not be
hypergamous as long as it's within
reason like i think every person men and
women are like wanting to get the best
partner that they can get like on both
ends so i think women want to get the
best partner they can get and men want
to get the best partner that we can get
the problem is and you guys are part of
the problem because you gass up these
fat chicks dude oh my gosh stop sleeping
fat chicks wait stop it i don't know how
about hold on stop sleeping with fat
chicks okay you're giving them the
validation yeah of thinking that they're
hotter than they are stop it okay stop
it if you think a girl like you would
not be seen in public with her stop it
stop effing these hoes and giving them
that validation you are part of the
problem i would agree if you don't
believe us after the stream do me a
favor
go find someone on your facebook who's
at 304 but like is overweight but still
post bikini pictures go look at the
comments
oh look at the comments y'all be gassing
these and then you're like why are these
women delusional why why would they be
it's because you tell them that they're
awesome when they look like lizzo i'm
like stop it
like if you're and here's the thing i
think guys i'm gonna be honest part of
the reason i lost so much weight was i
started seeing myself on camera i didn't
like the way i looked i was like god
damn
goddamn
and some of you guys bullied me a little
bit into losing weight i'm grateful for
you thank you keep doing it
watch me
watch me i want to say hot girl summer
because that's like a different they
think that's something else but watch
watch me look and find like i think a
little bit of bullying is good for
people let's bring back bullying yeah
bring it back
but then we're too hard on the women but
they're not hard like as if women are
not hard on other women also as if
they're not hard on men like miss me
with that one oh my god like
these hoes these
no guys stop i mean okay i don't usually
tell you guys what to do but i'm gonna
stand by this one yeah stop screwing the
whales stop it
stop it well also the crazy chicks too
like please stop stop you're like
validating their insanity because
they're like you know what but i could
get a man tonight if i wanted to and you
look at her like ma'am you need to be on
a mood stabilizer you're a criminal
you're insane you're a criminal you guys
give them the validation because you'll
be like oh easy easy sex right but
like these hoes are crazy and you're
letting them think they're not crazy
it's the worst
have you ever seen somebody simp over
like a bad single mom
like that to me i'm like sir you've
single-handedly ruined like three
generations of people
oh man
yeah but it's equal opportunity up in
here we know we know good women that we
like
yeah yeah if you
i know one
no rebecca we like rebecca
rebecca's great if you guys don't follow
her she's awesome yeah
but here's the thing like
if i was a dude this is what i would
look for if i was a dude i
but you know i'm biased right but i i
think like you should look for a girl
with a strong work ethic it doesn't have
to be like she's a career woman or
anything like i think it's important to
look for a girl that tries yeah and
she's gonna try for you yeah and that's
important because if she's if she's not
like putting her best foot forward for
you then like she doesn't value you like
if she's trying harder at her at her job
and everything else that she is to like
be in a relationship with you like she
doesn't she doesn't see you as valuable
yeah and like that's the thing like you
want to look
like i i would tell guys to go down and
looks to go up with like a girl that's
like actually into you because looks
fade guys like over time and like our
faces are gonna wrinkle it's not going
to be pretty and you want a girl like
that is so into you like that she's
willing to like drop all of all of the
sims that validate her although yeah i
actually don't think men should date
down i think like they're cucking
themselves
down
yeah okay yeah because uh well if they
got like a woman that was you know in
their league in the looks department
then it would be fair but when a man
dates down okay like my wife or my
girlfriend you know like i you know
she's not what i wanted but it'll it'll
do yeah like what ends up happening is
like those guys can get really resentful
and really mean over time
because
she's less than he went down right right
but then that feeds
the female delusion too which is like
that thing that we talk about so it's
like i think a problem that men are
getting down you're probably i guess i
think it's like okay if let's say a
guy's a seven he can get between a six
and an eight yeah i think so that's fair
so so i'm thinking like if you want to
get the hottest girl that you can get
like she's probably not going to be that
into you i so i agree yeah but if we all
unite
we all unite at the same time guys if
you have any plans with a woman today i
encourage you to try to go up by two
points in beauty go up by two points
once you get the two pointer then drop
the last chick i believe in you i
believe in you you never know she might
say yes stop screwing fat chicks i stand
by this
i stand by this
uh let's see if there's any other
questions
okay character wise having a good one oh
wait i was talking about what i would
say to look yeah and like a girl that
can control her weight like to like too
and understands that in that you need to
look for a girl that understands that
like marriage isn't about feelings it's
not about love it's a duty and it's
about responsibility yeah and like these
girls that think it's like a freaking
disney movie and it's just about love
and how you feel all the time like yeah
if you if you're married forever you're
gonna hate your husband you don't think
like one or two like you like yeah yeah
you probably will yeah like but you you
got to be the type of ride-or-die [ __ ]
to stick it out i've heard people say
that i've been married a long time you
know like seriously real talk they're
like the first five years like it was
not fun it was not fun but the sixth
year it's been great ever since and i'm
like woof like that's a commitment
that's a commitment but you know i've
heard that like multiple times that they
didn't like it at the beginning but they
figured it out and it ended up being
really awesome at the end but i only
hear that from couples that care about
how they look for one another like i
don't know why is that completely
balloon up i just don't like they're not
my friend group like
trying to um
post it on twitter pearl don't smash fat
[ __ ]
oh my god i should i should tweet that
stop smashing stop this stop banging
these whales that's why the women on
tick tock are mad at us we think they
think we're horrible but you know
we were fat isn't that
i had high blood pressure i was 24 years
old that's how fat i was well and you're
not like i'm sorry but when i'm
overweight i'm not as nice of a person
because because when you feel [ __ ] about
yourself you're not nice to the world
like yeah there's nothing better than
that feeling when you when you you look
snatched and you yeah
you could like you could go to the gym
your your shoulders are back and you
feel so good about yourself like
like i agree like you don't
like and i've heard guys say they're
attracted
to bigger girls but the problem is
they're so insecure about it
oh yeah they won't even be up front
and these are the same girls that scream
like body positivity and it's so sad
because it's just the girls like coping
like it's gross i girls will shame men
for like what they're attracted to
they're like now we're having ageism
like you're ageist because you don't
like older women
are you standard are you crazy like oh
you're you're fat phobic because you
don't like fat chicks
you don't call women heightest
because we don't like short guys like
i'm six foot call me and call me what
you want i like
like i like guys taller than me and it's
just
i don't know it's it's so irritating
because girls will shame guys but like
if a guy does the same thing
well yeah so the funny thing is like a
woman will be 200 300 pounds and like
guys like to the happy big women out
there we salute the rest y'all y'all are
like not fun we know because we see you
at the dmv
but in any case like aside from that
like you see the kind of men that they
attract and it's like always like a
broke bum like typically they're thinner
so like they hate it and you know what's
funny i knew a woman she got rejected
and you know she's like
on on the bad side of big and sh the guy
rejected her and he said that she was
like fat and ugly anyway and she was
like i don't know why he would say that
i don't know what he would say
because he was upset because he felt
like she was ugly enough that he could
smash and she rejected him and she like
she's so like delusional about like
what's going on with her body she hasn't
like processed that but she does want a
band but not enough to lose like 150
pounds because she's got to lose 150
pounds oh dear oh dear i gotta that's
that's a tough hell to apply i wanna i
gotta lose like 20 and i feel like
that's taking me forever
yes oh my gosh all right if i if i lose
20 more pounds then i'll be down 45 and
we can both say that online yeah hey we
can we can
um i'm getting tired of talking though
okay now we're good we're good okay oh
my god did you see the one comment that
was like i was like stop smashing fat
chicks and they're like we're not going
to stop
yo y'all are foul
we're not we're not gonna okay guys
thank you so much for getting us through
this car ride thank you this is fun yeah
it's gonna be good we're gonna eat
snacks we're gonna go to the beach at
some point yeah
yeah we're gonna we're gonna be chilling
i gotta take a final i'm so sad
oh my god and and guess guess can we
should we say like what we're doing
thursday night oh yeah yeah guys guys
guess where we're going thursday first
let's get excited
um we're we're going on um on solid
castle
oh my gosh probably you're the worst
sauce
yeah yeah so it's gonna be really
exciting and because i think i we got
offered to do this before i went viral
but i'm pretty sure that the fact that i
went viral is gonna come up so that
should be a lot of fun y'all wanna see
some hate you want to come through
come through pick me pick me up pick
misha
please i'd be lonely
okay guys thanks so much for watching
thank you so much for the donations
and i'll talk to you guys later bye